take over transportation for crew and
cargo
in low earth orbit while nasa was
pushing
in the deep space area
his work paid off bill and i united our
colleagues in the senate and house
and gained support for the 2010
authorization bill
which invested in both commercial space
program
that we have today and also nasa's own
deep space exploration capabilities
which we were pushing forward to do
it's incredible to see the path
chartered in 2010
that is being borne out today one of
both commercial partnership
and continued investment in our nation's
space
exploration capabilities
very soon nasa and spacex dragon
capsule will take off from kennedy space
center
the crew 2 mission will mark the third
commercial
crew flight to the international space
station
and nasa will soon do the same thing
with boeing and its starliner
spacecraft it was a competition that we
set
up for the commercial industry in that
2010 bill
within the next year nasa will launch
the space
launch system and orion
these are also authorized 2010
eventually returned u.s astronauts to
the moon
under the artemis program but the
challenges
aren't in the rear view as nasa embarks
on its artemis program
the agency needs a leader who not only
has a long standing
understanding of nasa's goals and
missions
but someone with political leadership
skills
who can build consensus and chart a bold
path
forward for nasa and our country
bill has the unique experience of
actually flying
in space and in an
unsurpassed record of supporting and
reforming the agency
keeping it vital through the bold policy
priorities including
critical science exploration aviation
and technology missions bill is the
leader
that nasa needs now i hope the committee
will act expeditiously and favorably on
his nomination
to get our programs up and going
and looking forward thank you so much
and it is great
and i'm so honored to be back with my
former colleagues
and those of you who are serving today
thanks for this welcome
thank you thank you ambassador hutchison
and again
i think it speaks very highly of senator
nelson of your nomination that
um two of your former republican
colleagues are here to join us and and
obviously speak
uh volumes about the work that you did
on the specific policy area
we'll now turn to more formal
introductions
of the next nominee lena khan and i will
turn to senator klobuchar to make her
remarks
well thank you very very much uh chair
chairman cantwell
and as well as ranking member wicker
congratulations to all the nominees
including senator nelson and i see his
family
it's good to see you again um and today
i have the honor of introducing
professor lena khan
as president biden's nominee to be a
commissioner at the federal trade
commission
she is joined by her husband dr
shah ali thank you for your work during
this pandemic
and her parents uh mr and mrs khan
i'm honored to have us today and you'll
be very proud of your daughter
uh nikon came to the united states
when she was 10 years old and she began
her career as a journalist
her experience digging deep analyzing
businesses
and searching for the truth brought her
to competition policy
and consumer protection as she
investigated and wrote about harms
that monopolization can inflict on
american consumers
now as the daughter of a reporter and a
sports writer myself
i think that journalism experience is a
really good thing
after her career as a journalist lena
moved on to a different kind of
public service as an advisor in the
office of commissioner rohit
chopra who we saw yesterday at the
hearing
we had in this very room at the federal
trade commission
they are professor khan draft crafted
policy
and cases from the inside then
as a legal director at the open markets
institute she sought to refresh
decades-old anti-trust law for the
modern digital era
pioneering new thinking about how
competition policy
impacts of the tech giants of our day
and what changes need to be made to make
a difference
lena ultimately went on to the house of
representatives
where she played a key role in the
development of their
groundbreaking gatekeepers report as
part of that job she also helped to
oversee the ftc
an agency where with the committee
support she can soon
be part of finally professor khan brings
serious
legal chops to the competition policy
table
she is an associate professor of law at
columbia university
and her work has been published in
wellwell
just about everywhere as the world has
noticed her
article on amazon which she wrote while
still in law school
went viral and not many law review
articles do that
and was described by the new york times
as reframing
decades of monopoly law and given the
interest of this committee from left to
right from liberal to conservative
in taking on antitrust and privacy
issues
i can't think of a more qualified person
to be considered for the ftc
lena khan is in short and out of the box
thinker
a pioneer in competition policy who is
already a noted expert
in her field her deep understanding of
how markets
influence our lives and how the law
should function
is exactly what we need at the ftc well
the ftc has done some
remarkable work including the recent
filing of the major case against
facebook
for too long mergers have gone
unchallenged and dominant firms
have accumulated levels of market power
that we have not seen in a
century these are some of the most
important issues of our day they are
complicated
and lena khan will bring a critical
perspective to the ftc
she's committed to using the agency's
authority to help solve real problems
and she has been committed to public
service as we can see
throughout her career i hope both
committee democrats
and republicans alike will look forward
to working with her on ensuring
that consumers get the benefit of free
and fair competition
that our innovative spirit in this
country brings new products and services
to markets that we continually
rejuvenate capitalism and that americans
are protected when they buy their
groceries go to a health clinic
buy their medicines and yes go on
facebook
we need lena kahn at the ftc and i urge
my colleagues to support the nomination
thank you very much thank you senator
klobuchar now we'll have
also an introductory statement by
senator blumenthal
thanks very much madam chair thank you
to all of the
nominees here today a particular welcome
to our colleague
bill nelson who has once again
demonstrated his extraordinary judgment
and wisdom by inviting his beautiful and
accomplished family to be with him
today uh we welcome you and look forward
to working with you
uh i have the tremendous honor to
introduce
lina khan whom i've long admired and i
want to thank
her family as well for their support
uh ms khan your story is so inspiring
an immigrant story an american story
about
extraordinary accomplishment but also
giving back
to america in such wonderfully
important and life-changing ways you've
already helped
countless people through your insights
and expertise
your amazing writings and so many
academic journals
but also your involvement in public
service in this congress in both
the senate and the house so you have
deep expertise and insight
tremendous experience and frankly the
guts and grit
that you've demonstrated already to
stand up to powerful
corporations and special interests that
now threaten competition
in this country and the fact is that
our nation is in an economic crisis we
need to revive our economy
but we need to do it in a way that
protects consumers
and in fact consumers have suffered
deeply as a result of this
pandemic the frauds and the
deception that has been involved in many
of the schemes that we see on the
internet
right now and the nation is also
in a privacy crisis
we've seen the intrusions and the
breaches of data that have occurred
we're in a competition crisis no one has
described it better than
you have and we thank you for calling
attention to the
effects of unchecked consolidation and
monopolization that preceded
the pandemic but have now been
aggravated and highlighted
during it so we are at a unique moment
for our nation's economy
one of recovery but at the same time
seeking greater equity
and competition that benefit consumers
ultimately
and you are indeed the right person
for this agency right now as the
chair of the subcommittee on consumer
protection in
this committee and a member of uh the
anti-trust supplement judiciary so ably
led by
senator kobachar i look forward to
working with you
on all of these areas and i look forward
to
the leadership that you will bring to
protecting consumers and competition as
a member of the
ftc and again thank you for your
willingness to serve thank you madam
chairman
thank you senator blumenthal and now
certainly
not least our former uh secretary of
commerce
uh secretary pritzker thank you so much
for joining us to speak to the
nomination
of ms kernan we we certainly miss you
and thank you for your service
good morning and thank you so much
chairman cantwell and ranking member
wicker
and the other members of the committee
for offering me the opportunity to speak
today
about my good friend leslie kiernan i'd
also
first like to congratulate the other
nominees as well
including my friend and uh former
senator bill nelson
and lena khan let me begin by
uh saying that serving as our nation's
38th u.s secretary of commerce was the
honor of a lifetime
and i really want to thank this
committee for giving me that opportunity
to serve our country
i thoroughly enjoyed working with each
and every one of you
on cr on the critical work to build a
stronger economy for all americans
and i really appreciated your
partnership
and your oversight role of the
department of commerce
so again i'm here today because i'm
really pleased to be able to speak about
my friend and former colleague leslie
kiernan
with whom i served in the obama
administration
she's someone for whom i have such great
respect and admiration
without hesitation i 100 percent support
her nomination
and know she will be if confirmed a
stellar
general counsel for the department of
commerce
leslie is a person of unquestioned
integrity
deep deep legal expertise
and a long tracker of proven results
demonstrated over the course of her
diverse career
in the private sector in government
and in the nonprofit world
she's also someone who's quite adept at
dealing with high pressure situations
and multitasking
given that he's the mother of four
wonderful children
fundamentally leslie is the servant
leader
who has robust experience in a broad
range of complex legal issues
that will serve the department of
commerce well
her expertise ranges from data
protection
and cyber security to environmental law
and corporate governance just to name a
few areas
make no mistake leslie is a lawyer's
lawyer
she's hired by her clients for her
astute expertise
and sound judgment and i know she will
apply the same true command of the law
and judgment
to the role of general counsel over the
course of her career
leslie's demonstrated a commitment to
bipartisanship
thoughtfully representing both democrats
and republicans
she's developed a reputation for
excellence
prophecy and discipline
frankly she's just a darn good lawyer
so it comes as no surprise that she's
being nominated
to such a crucial role
if confirmed leslie will work alongside
thousands of public servants at the
department of commerce
whom i deeply admire and respect
together i am confident they will work
tirelessly
to fulfill the agency's critical mission
to spur economic growth
and job creation for more americans
put simply i am very proud to know
leslie kiernan
i trust her judgment and i'm grateful
for her willingness to once again
serve our country the department of
commerce's success
as so many of you have said today is our
country's success
in my opinion leslie will serve both the
department
and secretary raimondo with distinction
so thank you again for inviting me to
join you today
and for the important work that all of
you do on behalf of our nation
i'm delighted to introduce to the
committee leslie and
kiernan and i enthusiastically
enthusiastically
endorse her swift nomination
thank you secretary pritzker thank you
so much for joining us and
uh taking the time to come back and make
sure the department of commerce gets a
strong team of
people working with them we appreciate
that now we're going to actually turn to
the nominees
again thank you for your willingness to
serve we're going to start with you
senator nelson again formally welcome to
the committee
and uh glad you're here to
assume hopefully this role and
responsibility
thank you madam chairman and if i may
submit my testimony in writing
for the record and if i may madam chair
just address the committee directly
go ahead yes first of all i want to
thank
my family
my spouse of going on 50 years
grace our daughter nian ellen
and virtually joining us from orlando
our son bill jr
i want to thank the co-panelists here
and congratulations to you
and everything that the two of you ms
khan miss kiernan that you have
already accomplished it's very
impressive
uh thanks to
my former colleagues
there's a a catch in my throat
when i think about the wonderful times
that i have had with you all
uh and the friendships that uh
have been bred over the
18 years that i was privileged to serve
here
and so your uh comments are just so
uh gratefully received
uh but now we have a big task ahead of
us and if you all
decide that you're going to confirm me
i look forward to this with uh gusto
and with enthusiasm there's a
lot of excitement going on in nasa right
now and you all have seen it you've seen
it
a couple of days ago with the flight
of the little helicopter on a
celestial body some 80
to 100 million miles away depending on
the orbits
that earth and mars are in
you've seen it as stated by the chairman
and the ranking member of the return
of american astronauts launching on
american vehicles
from american soil
later this year we're going to see it in
the launch
of the james webb telescope a 9 billion
dollar
instrument on top of an ariane
rocket situated at the equator at
the european space agency's
launch center in french guiana
you're going to see that telescope
replacing the hubble that has already
opened up
so many new things to us in the universe
and it's going to look back in time
almost to the beginning
of the source of life millions and
millions and billions
of light years away it's an exciting
time and at the end of the year perhaps
early next year you're going to see
the largest rocket ever
most powerful launched
that is going to be the workhorse on the
program
of going back to the moon and then on to
mars
which was a multi-administration
project these projects are not one
administration
there are many it's like building an
aircraft carrier
you start it and it'll take you years
down the road and it has to be continued
regardless of who's in the majority
regardless of who's
in the presidency and so too we are
seeing this and we will see the
fulfillment
of these programs and so if you
ask me what is my vision
for the future of nasa it is
to continue for us to explore
the heavens with humans
and with machines
and uh there is a lot of
excitement now corollary to that
is the fact of look at what
in developing machines that can take
humans and robots
out to explore look at
what is being developed in technology
and science and engineering
and mathematics first of all you're
going to see a spin-off
of a generation of newly educated young
people
think back to the apollo program and
think about how that ripple through
several generations of young people
in stem that made us
technologically the most advanced of all
the nations on the planet
that can be happening again
and pressing the envelope on the edges
of science
and discovery uh
look what is happening
think of the spin-offs that is coming
out of this
for our everyday lives i've got to reach
into my pocket here and
and tell you just recently i was
reminded
of one of the greatest spin-offs it's
the camera
in here now used
by billions of people on the planet
this camera was developed for the earth
observing satellites that
nasa has built and has operated
and i could go through so many other
things the canadian arm
first on the space shuttle and then on
now on the space station those robotics
think of the robotic surgery that i
ventured to say
some members of this committee may have
already experienced
including your witness
uh that has all been a spin-off
out of nasa technology madam chair
i am mindful of your time
i could keep going on and on and it's
hopefully in print
in my uh opening statement that i've
submitted to you i'm going to stop right
there i want to hear
from these other distinguished folks uh
thank you for the privilege i want to
say one other thing
i think the fact that marco and
kay would make a statement
tells you a lot about nasa
hopefully it tells you something about
me
uh in trying to bring people together
regardless of party
to build consensus in order to get
something done
i want to thank jim bridenstine the
former administrator
who did a remarkable job
under difficult circumstances
and as a result he became very popular
in nasa
i want to thank him for his friendship
his
very gracious comments to me
and so that's the spirit of nasa
to keep us going in a bipartisan indeed
nonpartisan way
uh in this regard nasa is like the
department of defense
there should be no partisanship as we
venture forth exploring
new horizons
thank you for the privilege of being
here thank you thank you
thank you senator nelson thank you for
your enthusiasm and your passion
we definitely feel it and we think it
will be put to good use
we'll now turn to miss khan for her
statement again welcome welcome to your
family thank you so much for your
willingness to serve
for the opportunity to be here today
especially with such esteemed panelists
i am deeply honored to have been
nominated by president biden
to serve as a commissioner of the
federal trade commission
and i am so grateful to my family
friends colleagues
mentors and students for their
encouragement and support
i'd especially like to recognize my
parents my brother and my husband who
are here with me today
and my other brother parents-in-law and
grandmother who are all
watching online for the last decade i
have focused on studying and
investigating markets
across our economy and examining the
laws that enable honest and fair
competition
i first started this work as a
journalist and policy analyst
where my job was to document the state
of competition across industries
and to uncover the abusive business
practices that excessive concentration
can enable
i spent years studying markets ranging
from chicken farming and airlines to
aluminum and book publishing
and learning from entrepreneurs and
small businesses about the obstacles
that they face
this work taught me the importance of
fair competition
and the critical role that the antitrust
laws play in encouraging business
dynamism
and promoting widespread prosperity
i have built on this work as a legal
scholar where my focus has been to
examine the history of america's
anti-monopoly laws
this history reveals our long tradition
of safeguarding core liberties through
promoting competitive markets
and the wide arsenal of tools we have
used to protect our economy
and our democracy from unchecked
monopoly power
studying this tradition lets us mine our
past for lessons we can apply
when navigating challenges today i have
also had the chance to work on
competition issues through government
service
first at the federal trade commission
and most recently as counsel to the
house judiciary committee's
subcommittee on antitrust commercial and
administrative law
while in the house i helped lead a
16-month bipartisan investigation into
digital markets
a top to bottom empirical review of how
these markets are functioning
pursuing this investigation underscored
the important work that enforcers and
lawmakers must do
to ensure that long-standing laws are
keeping pace
with new technologies and reflecting
current business realities
congress created the federal trade
commission to serve as a guardian of
fair competition
and to protect consumers workers and
honest businesses
from unfair and deceptive trade
practices
if confirmed i look forward to working
with my fellow commissioners
the career staff this committee and the
broader public
to pursue the agency's mission with
vigor and a deep commitment
to serving the american public thank you
and i look forward to your questions
thank you miss khan and again thank you
for your willingness to serve
in this capacity ms kernan again thank
you welcome
uh we look forward to hearing your
remarks chair cantwell
ranking member wicker and members of the
committee
i'm honored to appear before you today
as president biden's nominee to serve as
general counsel of the department of
commerce
i am grateful for and humbled by the
trust and confidence
that president biden and secretary
raimondo have placed in me
if confirmed i will work hard to justify
that trust
i would also like to thank the committee
for considering my nomination
and i appreciate the opportunity i've
had to meet with members of your staff
before this hearing i want to thank
secretary pritzker for those very
gracious remarks
i appreciate her support and value her
friendship
i also want to thank my husband paul and
our four children
caroline kate christopher and william
for their
encouragement and support the department
of commerce has approximately 47
000 employees working across a wide
range of offices and bureaus
the people of the commerce department
are working on communications policy
international trade weather fisheries
and patents
they help foster innovation by setting
standards and conducting
foundational research they are united by
their mission of promoting the
conditions for economic growth and
opportunity
their work touches the lives of every
american probably every day
the department's ability to fulfill its
mission is critically important
as the country seeks to recover from the
economic damage
caused by the pandemic and to protect
american
competitiveness from the unfair trade
practices of
china and other nations together with
the more than 300 career lawyers and
other professionals who make up the
office of general counsel
the general counsel plays a critical
role in advancing the department's
mission
by providing high quality legal advice
and counsel
to the secretary and officials
throughout the department
as the department's chief legal officer
the general counsel is responsible for
ensuring that the laws congress has
enacted are faithfully implemented and
enforced
the general counsel represents the
department before
other agencies works with the department
of justice to represent the commerce
department in court
and provides leadership guidance and
support to the many talented and
committed lawyers
who work at the department i believe my
experience in the private sector and in
government has prepared me for this
position
and given me an understanding of the
appropriate role of the general counsel
i've worked for over 30 years in private
practice and in government
early in my career i worked on the staff
of the house committee on banking
finance and urban affairs
i have private practice and government
experience in a wide range of legal
matters
providing leadership and advice on
litigation enforcement
ethics and compliance i also had the
privilege of serving as deputy counsel
to the president
in the obama biden administration where
i provided advice on a variety of legal
policy and oversight issues and worked
closely with the general counsels and
other senior lawyers
of departments and agencies throughout
the government
i have seen how important it is that
agencies work together
and that everyone is guided by doing
what the law and the constitution
require
rigorous legal analysis and good
lawyering are essential if government is
to work best for the people
through my experiences in government and
in the private sector
i have learned a lot about leadership
problem solving and the importance of
collaboration
i'm a strong believer in teamwork and if
confirmed pledged to seek op
opportunities to work closely with this
committee
and to be responsive to your requests
for information
and assistance this is a particularly
interesting and exciting time to work in
the commerce department
as it supports innovation and
opportunities for all americans and
businesses
the department requires and deserves the
best possible legal advice
as it navigates the challenges it faces
and the opportunities it is presented if
confirmed i commit to you
that i will do my best to provide that
advice and counsel
thank you again for the opportunity to
appear before you
i look forward to your questions thank
you ms kernan and thank you for uh
persevering
i i think some uh air system went on in
the middle of your testimony so if
everybody here's a low hum
uh that's what it is we'll just have to
persevere through this and so they're
trying to
trying to address it i'm sure it's not
great for the broadcast entities that
are here
well it's a little lower anyway we'll
keep working on it
now we're going to turn to questions and
um obviously if the witnesses could help
us out here a little bit since there's
uh three of you senator nelson i wanted
to start with you
obviously nasa has a big tradition
of ensuring resiliency in commercial
programs by using multiple competitors
and maintaining what's called
dissimilar redundancy so i i want to
know that you'll commit to
rapidly providing congress with a plan
for assuring that kind of resiliency
out of the human lander program i do
thank you competition is always good
thank you
and on the workforce issue um artemis is
a great mission
now there are 18 astronauts that are
going to be competing for that there are
a few from the state of washington we're
very proud of them
but i think importantly it shows that in
2019
women only made up one-third of nasa's
workforce and 16
of the senior scientific workforce
if confirmed will you promote diversity
of rules for women in technical and
leadership roles throughout nasa
yes ma'am and already have and
i strongly recommend it to the white
house
that the deputy be a woman
who is exceptionally qualified and
indeed
i think you will see that in the person
that was announced
last week pam melroy
a former astronaut commander
before that she was air force colonel
test pilot after nasa she went to the
faa
and then to darpa and so
she is an incredibly prepared person
as well as being a delightful person
and she and i will operate as
a team although the white house hasn't
announced yet
they are i think looking at the third
person
in nasa and you only uh senate confirm
three
the chief financial officer and i
believe that they are looking
at whom we have recommended uh
also a woman thank you thank you miss
khan
uh one of the things that the committee
as ranking member we did was issue a
report on journalism and the market
impacts that local journalism has faced
in the transformation to the information
age
google and facebook play dominant roles
as portals to news and media
i think you probably understand the
challenges that these sectors
have have faced given this um
given this level of activity
do you think that the ftc should review
google and facebook's use of
journalistic content without
compensation
under the unfair uh the unfairness
standard that the ftc has
you want to hit your mic yeah thank you
thank you
thank you senator and congratulations to
you and your staff for such an incisive
report
um i think you know we everything needs
to be on the table um obviously local
journalism
is in crisis and i think the current
covet moment has really underscored
the deep democratic emergency that is
resulting when we don't have reliable
sources of local news
so absolutely you know this would be
something that i would hope to focus on
at the commission
what uncompetitive practices do you see
going on
so i think there are two major factors
um
one of which is the fact that you know
increasingly news publishers are
dependent
on a few gatekeepers to disseminate
their news and to disseminate their
information
and so a single change in an algorithm
can plummet
readership and subscriptions for any
publisher and so i think there's some
concerns generally there about
the arbitrary whims and the arbitrary
power that these sperms can exercise
i think there are also serious concerns
about concentration within the digital
ad market
as well as vertical integration that has
potentially created some conflicts of
interest
some of the lawsuits that were filed
last year i think underscore these
issues
um as well as potential you know
criminal activity as well so i think
it'll be important to continue seeing
how those lawsuits play out as well
thank you well we're going to continue
our work here because we think
you know we we believe in the model that
um
that our markets our economy needs
perfect information
that's what basically generates true
data
but if you think that markets need
perfect information
well if you have such a decline in
journalism you're not going to get
perfect information so
we definitely want a diversity of voices
and foias and holding people accountable
and all of those things so thank you
uh miss kernan um one of the key
challenges that we face
when uh we're dealing with um
uh when we're dealing with noaa
and or other aspects of commerce is
responsibilities given to the
organization and timely
allocation of those resources so i could
say for example tribal broadband money
or noaa disaster commercial assistance
will you commit to making sure the
agency works
closely with all of us on timely
distribution of resources
obviously accurate distribution but
timely
because so many of these represent very
small entities who are counting on these
resources
yes senator absolutely and will you
commit
uh i mentioned in the beginning about
the scientific integrity
uh in the aftermath of hurricane dorian
the inspector general for the department
of commerce found that the former acting
general counsel
interfered with science even going as
far to draft public statements
rebuking career scientists at the
national weather service
if confirmed will you ensure that the
office of
your general counsel office always
follows science
yes senator thank you um senator wicker
thank you madam chair and uh senator
nelson uh i think it's wonderful to see
both you
and senator hutcheson uh before the
committee
back before the committee today and it
speaks volumes that
uh having uh completed her introduction
she remains uh on the on the call
uh remotely as a supporter so uh
welcome back to both of you uh let me
ask about the artemis program
uh i i was i was excited about the idea
of
a lunar landing in 2024
and a mars landing in um in
2029 that timetable has
slipped could you discuss that just uh
briefly
and and discuss how we move
quickly but safely uh
and uh and prevent the timetable from
slipping
uh even further yes sir
uh understand that they won't let me get
into the innards because i
still can't talk to nasa until you all
may decide to confirm me
uh however uh the uh
press conference and the public
statements that were made
by the deciding authority on the
competition
for the first landing human landing
crew landing on the moon
as it was explained by the nasa official
making that determination
the timetable for 2024
is still there with the
uh awardee and
i think we all have to recognize that
space
is hard and it's an ambitious
timetable but that is what has been
stated
now coming after that this is a
demonstration of
landing a crew on the surface of the
moon
and returning them safely uh after that
there's a lot of activity that can go on
before we eventually create the
spacecraft that will go to mars
and those are going to be future
competitions the
the chair uh ask about competitions
and those competitions will be there
as articulated by the deciding authority
on this competition
so i i think uh you may be pleased
that we're going to see that timetable
try to be adhered to but
recognize that with some sobering
reality that space is hard
thank you very much senator and uh i
hope that optimistic
answer uh turns out to uh to
in fact be uh be accurate and i want to
do what i can
to help it be accurate let me turn
quickly into
uh lena khan thank you for your
willingness to serve
um you wrote um an interesting
paper entitled amazon's antitrust
paradox where you discuss applying
common carrier
regulations to big tech
um are you familiar with uh
uh with justice thomas's uh recent
uh publication with regard uh to that
and uh do you think common carrier
regulations can be applied
to social media companies like twitter
facebook
and youtube and uh please explain
um why or why not
thank you senator um yes i did get a
chance to read justice thomas's
concurrence the other week i think
it you know prompted a lot of
interesting discussion
i'm in in the amazon article you know
i've really identified
two potential pathways forward when
thinking about these dominant digital
platforms
one is enforcing competition laws and
ensuring that these markets are
competitive
and the other is you know if we instead
recognize that perhaps there are certain
economies of scale
network externalities that instead are
going to lead these markets to
stay dominated by a very few number of
companies
then we need to apply a different set of
rules and we have a long legal tradition
of thinking about what types of
uh checks can we apply when you actually
have a lot of concentration and common
carriage is one of those tools so i
think fundamentally we need to kind of
choose one of these paradigms
um and proceed accordingly
but but in your view uh one or the other
uh is uh is going to be necessary
to fix a broken system is that correct
yes and i should clarify that you know
some of these firms are now integrated
in so many markets
that you may uh reach for a different
set of tools depending on which specific
market you're looking at so i think we
need to be a bit market specific but yes
overall i think we need to choose one or
the other thank you very much thank you
madam chair
senator klobuchar thank you very much
i'll start with you ms khan
senator canwell was asking about the
problems for newspaper publishers and
news in general
we all know what happened in australia
where literally google and facebook
tried to hold the whole country hostage
um didn't work but they tried um and so
are you aware of the bill that senator
kennedy and i have with the companion
with representative sicilini and
representative buck
which has senator mcconnell was one of
the co-authors last year
that allows the newspapers and the other
news organizations to
combine their negotiating power to be
able to get a better content rates
um and just your thoughts on that yes i
am familiar with it and i should say
thank you so much for the generous
introduction earlier
um you know i think these types of
exemptions that allow coordination have
traditionally been used by congress in
instances where you have deep
asymmetries of power within the market
um so you know historically um congress
passed an anti-trust exemption for
workers in order to allow them to
coordinate
similarly with ad co-ops and so in
instances where there just seem to be
deep fundamental asymmetries of power i
think that type of tool makes sense
insofar as this is a market where we see
that asymmetry i think you know it could
be one step forward certainly
i like your answer to center wicker
about how you have to look at different
markets in different situations
differently and one thing we're having a
hearing this afternoon with senator
blumenthal and
uh senator lee and others on our
antitrust subcommittee on the
app store markets uh which i think
a lot of citizens would be stunned to
know that which i know you know
uh that um for a lot of companies that
decide there wanna need to be on either
google
or um or apple's app store markets it's
13 30 off the top it's somewhere between
15 and 30
uh that goes out of the pockets of
really consumers
um and to these app stores these
companies
and um it's also kind of stunning to
know
that they ban companies that advertise
in one of those app stores are banned
from
telling their customers they could get a
better deal on their website
um and i just don't know what argument
you can make for that so do you want to
talk a little bit about this issue as
senator blumenthal and i head to this
hearing this afternoon
yeah certainly it's a significant issue
and as you noted it's really
um the source of the power is the fact
that you have you know basically these
two
these two main options right and so that
gives these companies the power to
really set the terms in this market
in some cases um i think we wrote that
certain terms and conditions really
lack any type of you know beneficial
justification and so i think in those
cases we need to be especially
skeptical and really look closely and
then
finally something that's really relevant
because we're trying to get this done
quickly uh senator grassley and i uh
have joined forces and have
a bill that restructures the fees that
have been done since heart scott rodino
for the mega mergers and actually
reduces them on some of the smaller
mergers
that are paid in in order to give the
resources to
the ftc and doj antitrust which are
shadows of their former selves from even
the
reagan era this was supported by the
trump administration this bill
at the very end of last year's um chief
staff meadows was
trying to help us to get in as well
making
chair simons the former chair of the ftc
um as well as many basically had gotten
through the senate
um impromptu so talk about the need for
resources to take on the biggest
companies that the world has ever known
yeah i mean as you well noted you know
the the resources of the commission have
not really
really kept pace with the increasing
size of the economy as well as the
increasing size and complexity of the
deals that the commission is reviewing
and so i think
you know measures like the one that
you're discussing could make a lot of
sense to help out
very good i'll turn to you miss kieran
um travel and tourism
i'm one of the co-chairs of that caucus
and just very briefly because i want to
end with senator
nelson the brand usa
talk about that the importance of that
for
promoting our country the center and i
have worked on
extensively
senator i think helping the
tourism and travel industry recover from
the damages of the pandemic
is a priority of the department
and i certainly look forward to working
with you
and the other members of the committee
on
on that effort and in particular if
there are legal issues that
are impacting or delaying our
ability to address these issues promptly
i would certainly commit to
making resolving those a priority thank
you and then
last um senator nelson congratulations
you and i on the phone talked about
um your devotion to making sure more
women and people of color
get into science and nasa is such a
great vehicle
an aspiring vehicle for that purpose
and so they're no longer hidden figures
um
the title of that wonderful movie could
you just briefly
um explain how important this is to you
well it is as the president has said uh
he wants the government to reflect
america
and uh we're certainly going to try to
do that at nasa and i think we've
already gotten a good start i'll just
point out one thing
that you may not know way back at the
beginning
you know all the astronauts were test
pilots
they were all men they were white men
they had to be a certain size
uh that was coming out of uh mercury
gemini and uh apollo
but when they got to the space shuttle
there was a lady named nichelle nichols
who had become a a tremendous
symbol for the african-american
community
because she played lieutenant ahura
on star trek and
she and nasa got together and she
reached out
because african americans didn't
think that they would ever be selected
in the application for an astronaut
whether it be a pilot astronaut or the
mission specialist
and because she reached out
affirmatively
she was able to get so in that first
class of space shuttle astronauts
there were quite a few women and quite a
few
uh people of of color
uh very successfully so that
uh when i was privileged to fly
in the early part of the space shuttle
program
sitting in the right seat was
an african-american a marine colonel
later a general charlie bolden who later
became administrative in
nasa uh and our
capcom was fred gregory
the first african-american
astronaut to fly as an as a pilot
astronaut so
uh but there's plenty of opportunity for
expansion in the future and we're going
to try to do that
thank you thank you so much senator
thune
thank you chair cantwell and thanks to
all of our nominees
congratulations on your nominations and
uh senator nelson
welcome back the committee uh it's good
to see you here if it's even it's on the
other side of the diocese
we uh accomplished a great deal during
our time as uh as chair and ranking
member of this committee due in large
part to our excellent working
relationship and even when
we did disagree i always knew that i
could count on you
uh to work in a fair and straightforward
manner to
resolve any issues and to carry on our
committee's business
and i can't tell you how pleased i was
to hear the news that the president
nominated you for this position
it is you're the perfect person
supremely qualified and i look forward
to the possibility of working with you
in this new role and nice to see
grace welcome back good to have you here
as well um and i
am appreciative too of the fact that you
were willing to come to south dakota
um and we took you several thousand feet
underground
to look at some work that's being done
out there in the black hills and of
course i was privileged
to have the opportunity to go with you
to the florida everglades
um i don't know do you guys you can get
that photo up or not
they're working on it okay i think we
have a photo of our uh trip down there
and um when they get that out ball we'll
come back to it oh there it is
okay oh my gosh okay
yeah yeah i might say
when that snake turned around and
started looking at john
uh he decided it was time to turn it
over to the other side yeah yeah that's
right
the the instincts kick in but anyway
great trip um i learned a lot
about about your state um senator nelson
as uh as you know very well nasa has
inspired
the young people to pursue stem careers
so becoming the next generation of
scientists and engineers
to propel the nation space program
forward not to mention the numerous
other societal and economic benefits
associated with space exploration and
though
south dakota doesn't have a direct nasa
presence the state participates in both
the space grant project
and nasa's epscor program which provide
young people with opportunities to
understand and participate in nasa
projects they also provide
workforce development education tools
that benefit regional economies and
advance the u.s
research enterprise particularly in
rural states where such assistance can
be otherwise unavailable
it confirmed how would you work to build
upon the success of these programs to
improve
nasa's stem engagement
to do senator exactly what we did
together in the past the stem
grant program is very important to
universities
in every state whether that state
has a nasa facility
or a center or not the stem program
is just incredibly important in
science engineering technology and
mathematics
uh also you mentioned the escort program
that is a recognition that some states
don't get as much in
federal spending as other states
and so it gives a nod to those states
in the kind of federal spending that
would come in
in this particular case in those
technology stem
fields so i look forward to
doing that with you and i look forward
to
returning to south dakota with you
and uh uh take me down into that
abandoned gold mine again uh one mile
underneath the surface of the earth
that's quite a place we'd love to have
you back
um as you know nasa works
collaboratively with industry to deliver
payloads and crew crews to low earth
orbit
and eventually beyond as a number of
commercial operators and the diversity
of their missions
grow could you describe how if confirmed
you would work to ensure that nasa plays
a constructive role
in a cohesive and focused vision across
both government-sponsored
and commercial missions and that
is building on the law that senator kay
bailey hutchinson
a while ago that we had passed back in
2010 which is the dual course
and it sets nasa on that course 11 years
ago
for the future and that is one course
is the commercial operations instead of
everything being done by nasa
have those commercial operations it was
originally thought that that was going
to be
just in low earth orbit such as the
delivery
of cargo and crew by commercial
operators
to the international space station which
is now
an accomplished fact with spacex
just about in a few days to launch a
crew again
uh and later in the year uh boeing uh
doing the same
uh others uh are supplying cargo
but having done that with the commercial
operators get nasa
out of low earth orbit and let nasa go
explore
and uh then uh the question is the
lander
well this is a landing of humans on the
surface of the moon
and nasa just announced
uh its down select on a contract
on a demonstration of landing
on the moon with a crew and bringing
them back safely
and we talked about that just a few
minutes ago
about that is described by nasa in their
press conference
that it will be in 2024
and then there are so many other
commercial contracts to come
after that uh
depending on the progress
of what is you want to do on the surface
of the
of the moon but particularly in the
preparation
to go to mars mars is the goal
in the decade of the 2030s and uh
i think you'll see this dual activity
continue
as set by law in the 2010 bill
thank you and great to have you back
madam chair
uh i will yield back my time to expired
i do want to for the record ask a
question of miss khan about her thoughts
on the ftc's suit against facebook
so let me get that thank you thank you
thank you and i think i'll follow up
with
a question for the record to senator
nelson on this issue because
clearly i think there needs to be
redundancy and it has to be clear
this process can't be redundancy later
it has to be redundancy now
so we'll follow up with a question on
that senator blumenthal thanks madam
chair
uh again welcome back senator nelson
um i'm delighted that you will have
this role and uh really inspired by your
opening statement
i want to ask a question about the
sourcing of contracts
by nasa because so much depends on
having a supply chain and a reliable
source of the components and parts
that go into these
projects and frankly make it look easy
when in fact it is a
diverse combination of many many
contractors
in our call earlier this week i raised
the critical role that connecticut plays
in the aerospace industry companies like
collins aerospace and windsor locks are
working to
develop for example the next generation
of space suits
people take for granted of course we'll
walk on mars
of course we'll have men and women on
the moon
but the next generation of spacesuits is
going to be critical to enable him
to do so and as you well know from your
experience
as a united states senator there are
many many small companies that are
simply looking for a
fair playing field competitive
outlook when they are bidding in
this kind of environment so i know that
you
are sensitive to that
challenge of opening opportunities for
contractors and sub contractors and
that nasa is hoping to commercially
procure
maintain and service those kinds of
components like spacesuits um
do you think that um it's possible to
source them competitively as opposed to
just going to one source i do
senator uh and competition is always
better
than sole sourcing uh because you can
get the efficiencies and you get
the lower price uh and so
uh indeed and you talk about the
supply chain which is so critical one of
the things that has held us up on
artemis on the big rocket
the sls that will launch later this year
there has been some slowing down of the
supply chain because of covet
and because of natural disasters
hurricanes etc
but it's just amazing
in american industry how the supply
chains
provide what is needed ultimately to the
product
and uh that's very important that we
keep that going
so thank you for raising that thank you
uh i i really welcome that answer um ms
khan
uh you mentioned there are two paradigms
uh
paradigms are theoretical constructs or
models
but the ftc is
an enforcement agency and the best
paradigms the best laws
are dead letter if they aren't enforced
vigorously
and the ftc right now has a complaint
against facebook uh are will you be
committed to vigorously
enforce that complaint and other
laws that are under your responsibility
absolutely senator
and what do you see as the biggest
challenge for enforcement when it comes
to big tech is it the size of
big tech its resources and power uh
lack of resources on the part of the ftc
can the ftc
really enforce the law against behemoth
corporations like facebook google
amazon i think one of the challenges is
just the deep
information asymmetries that exist
between some of these firms and
enforcers and regulators um you know i i
think it's
clear that in some instances the
agencies have been a little slow to
catch up to the underlying business
realities and the empirical realities of
how these markets work
and so i think at the very least you
know ensuring that the agencies are
doing everything they can to keep pace
is going to be important and
beyond the kind of marquee tasks of
enforcement
big tech and so forth there's also the
continuing challenges of everyday
americans
i'm reminded of one joey robinson of
stratford connecticut who wrote to me
about her struggle to find legitimate
ppe
personal protective equipment to keep
safe during the pandemic she told me
that
after extensive research
she was still swindled she wrote
quote they have my money and i have no
ppe
no way to get them to refund me after
literally hours on hold and more than a
dozen
efforts in writing
in effect she told me no one was
listening no one was doing
anything and there are at least
451 000 this is
ms robinson's out there according to the
ftc
zone data i uh
would be interested in your views as to
the responsibilities of the ftc
to those kinds of everyday american
consumers
yeah absolutely i mean this type of
fraud and these scams are obviously a
huge issue especially during a time like
the pandemic where they really have life
or death consequences
um congress recently gave the commission
additional civil penalty authority with
regards to unfair deceptive practices in
the context of kovid
and so i would hope at the very least
that the agency would vigorously use
that authority
thank you thank you senator fisher
thank you senator cantwell miss khan i
appreciated speaking with you before the
hearing
and i know we had reviewed your
experience on antitrust policy
and you mentioned that you got started
studying these issues within the poultry
industry context uh in my own work i've
been pushing for more transparency and
competition in cattle markets
recently there's been quite a bit of
producer sentiment that the cattle
market is on the
brink of major vertical integration
following trends
that we have seen in poultry and pork
industries as we look at the forces that
can lead to
significant consolidation what factors
jump out to you as red flags that could
indicate the tipping point
for an industry recognizing as you
mentioned previously that this may vary
by market
yeah thanks for the question senator and
i really enjoyed our our opportunity to
discuss these issues
um i mean i think agriculture is a
sector where we see
some of the most extreme examples of
these trends where you both
you know concentration and medical
integration
in ways that really leave farmers and
ranchers dependent on you know sometimes
one entity and that type of relationship
also of course
can lead to certain types of asymmetries
and the ability to dictate terms and so
i think all of those you know factors
are really important to look at
when trying to assess these issues
uh if you're confirmed as a commissioner
how would you
or how would this inform your approach
to reviewing competition
and in this how would you specifically
look to mitigate
harmful effects for consumers
yes so the ftc has limited jurisdiction
um in the context of agriculture markets
as kind of like
retail onwards in the food supply chain
so at the very least ensuring that the
ftc is vigorously enforcing the law
um over the markets in the food supply
chain where it does have authority so
that we don't have a situation where
consolidation down here you know
upstream uh exacerbates consolidation
i think that'll be um that'll be one
important thing to focus on
thank you senator nelson good to see you
again
nasa and the contractors that it works
with invest
heavily based on priorities established
by congress
and carried out by the administration in
your opinion
how important is it for nasa and nasa's
contractors to have
continuity in its programs and missions
such as the artemis program
and the space launch system it's very
important
and as i have tried to articulate
space is hard and space takes a long
time
to develop these technologies and this
is cutting-edge stuff
so it didn't just start yesterday it
started
years ago senator k bailey hutchinson
indicated how it
had started with the legislation
back in 2010 so uh it's
it's very important to keep this
continuity going
from year to year extremely important
okay thank you and again good to see you
miss kiernan you listed the department
of commerce's i.t
and cyber security posture among what
you believe
are the top challenges facing the
department
in the wake of recent major cyber
security breaches
of federal agencies could you please
describe what you see as the most
significant hurdles for the commerce
department here
senator protecting our networks
is vital to our economic and national
security
nist's cyber security network has
improved cyber security awareness and
facilitated
regulatory streamlining since i'm not at
the agency
i don't have all the current details on
the department's efforts in this regard
but if confirmed i will make it a
priority to work with the experts at
nist
and in other agencies throughout the
government on these issues
if you are confirmed as general counsel
how would you
advise the department to approach these
challenges
senator i think that this is a
an issue that is one that requires
government-wide responses it will be
incredibly important to work with
other agencies throughout the government
and to get the best ideas from experts
in the private sector
given the challenges that we face we
need to
ensure that we are utilizing best
practices and that we are reaching out
to
the experts throughout the government
and
in the private sector in order to bring
those to bear
thank you thank you madam chair
thank you uh senator tester is next
thank you madam chair um this is for
um uh nominee khan and
it goes kind of on the same line senator
was asking
um questions um
i'm in agriculture um and
agriculture's the number one industry in
montana
and feeding people is really really
important in fact
i think uh you can control people with
food
more than you can control with anything
else and we've had
we've had the luxury of having an
incredible production agriculture
economy that has fed the world
not just recent years but for some time
we've watched consolidation creep into
agriculture in the chicken industry and
the pork industry
in the beef industry and the grains
we even we even see it in in in pulses
and
uh and crops like that um this isn't
amazon it's not facebook it's not new
technology
they've been the big processors been
doing this for
decades and decades and
and i would say that no administration
democrat or republican has tackled this
in my lifetime yeah and i've seen
this consolidation result in rural
communities drying up
no competition in the marketplace both
on the when you sell goods and
when you buy inputs uh you're totally
locked into a group of three or four
people who could basically go on a golf
course and determine what's going to be
paid in the marketplace
capitalism is not working so my question
to you
uh nominee khan is you're a smart person
you know about consolidation
but i think the reason that many of the
administrations in the past haven't
dealt with this is because
these companies control a lot of money
and they can throw a lot of power
and they can put that influence into the
re-election campaigns of many people
that said on this panel and a whole
bunch of others
how are you how are you going to deal
with the consolidation issue and how are
you going to deal with it from a
political standpoint
thank you senator um you know as you as
you noted i think there's a long history
of recognizing the ways in which
concentration of economic power can
translate into political power and so i
think those types of dynamics are ones
that you know we face across the board
um in the context of agriculture more
specifically
it's the justice department that
primarily has jurisdiction in the
antitrust domain
um over some of these markets i also
think that the packers and stockyards
act is a real
hidden gem of a statute that in some
ways was really designed to really
head on address some of these
consolidation issues in the context of
agriculture so
you know reviving that statute and its
enforcement would be another
step forward um i also think you know
the agriculture markets are a really
interesting example of some of the
um additional effects that concentration
has in so far as concentration of the
food supply can also lead to all sorts
of fragility issues
which can you know come to the surface
in particular during times of crisis so
absolutely i think these are really
really important issues
so i i want to carry on on this line of
questioning really quick nominee khan
and that is
that you said for the most part this is
in the justice department's
realm um look what i have seen
in my 14 years here on the hill is
in many different issues broadband is a
prime example when you have many
different agencies that are in charge of
putting fiber in the ground
or when you have a couple agencies in
charge of dealing with consolidation
in the food they point the finger at one
another what do you intend to do
on the ftc in this realm
that is legal within the law for you to
do
yeah interestingly the ftc's
jurisdiction over agriculture markets
was actually stripped
after the ftc published a big report on
the meat packers in 1920
so when the ftc did try to go hard here
you know it's jurisdiction of a script
but
as i mentioned earlier you know the ftc
does have jurisdiction over
um kind of downstream in the in the food
system so especially in the context of
food retail grocery
and so in so far as sometimes you know
concentration and or consolidation in
one part of the supply chain can
exacerbate consolidation in another part
um i think at the very least ensuring
that the ftc is
you know fully enforcing the law over
the food markets that it does have
jurisdiction over it's going to be
important
well i appreciate that um i will tell
you as somebody that's involved in
production agriculture i
i would hope that we would get some
folks that would
would tackle the agribusiness
multinational
uh agri-business companies that quite
frankly
um i just i just think that they've
not allowed capitalism to work the way
it should and that's my opinion and
it'll be my opinion until i learn
otherwise
i have a second left so i just want to
say it's good to see you senator
hutchison
and it's good to see you senator nelson
uh and good luck to you both in whatever
your endeavors are and i know
nelson it's nasa and i expect you to
move uh
the launch pad up to montana that's in
cape canaveral but if you don't do that
i'm still gonna vote for you
and kay it's really good to see you take
care of you guys
thank you thank you chester thank you
for those questions i
i i want to echo his comments i i see
this all the time
in uh pricing of agriculture product in
the pacific northwest
there's just too much a concentration of
power in setting
the price and we need to we're either
going to look for
new competition or we have to figure out
exactly what that market influence
is that is just two so the channels
in the in the uh uh i'm sorry the
verticals there
are just you know putting too much
pressure on on
on on the price so anyway okay we're
turning to senator moran
for this hearing uh i had an opportunity
to meet
both with uh ms khan and with senator
nelson and i appreciate those
conversations they were valuable to me
i i don't have any questions for you
senator nelson i wish you well and i
look forward to working with you
both in the commerce committee and the
appropriations committee in regard to
nasa and our future space opportunities
including
aviation and aerospace in kansas let me
ask
ms khan a question about social media
i've become increasingly concerned about
social media companies
that promise to be free and open
marketplace for ideas
but they're not in my view of holding
those promises to their consumers
i've introduced the promise act that
would require social media companies to
implement operate and disclose
information
moderation policies and would prohibit a
social media company from making a
deceptive policy statement
quote unquote violations of this law
under that legislation would constitute
an unfair or deceptive act or practice
in violation of section 5
of the federal trade commission act what
do you see as the role of the ftc in
making certain that social media
companies are abiding by their public
statements and policies
when it comes to content moderation
thank you senator um i think you know as
i mentioned earlier in the exchange with
senator blumenthal i think the
information asymmetries are so
here are so deep and that at the very
least we really need the federal trade
commission to be using its information
collection capacities to really try and
mitigate some of these
information gaps um you know social
media we have
black box algorithms you know
proprietary algorithms that can
sometimes make it difficult to know
what's really going on
the ftc did in the last couple of years
use its 6b authority to start
trying to get some of more of this
information so hopefully you know that
will provide some more transparency but
um in general i think you know the
commission's information collection
authorities can be useful here
thank you i think our legislation
is a means by which we can deal with
activities that are contrary to stated
policy by the companies
without necessarily dealing with section
230
which has significant consequences for
entrepreneurs and small business
startups
so i look forward to further
conversations with you and the ftc if
if this legislation in particular uh
moves forward let me turn to ms
uh kiermann um
solarwinds cyber attack exposed serious
deficits in the country's cyber defenses
the department of commerce was one of
the first departments to be identified
as being breached as part of that attack
solar wind's compromise was as much an
attack on our
excuse me economic security as it is our
national security
and vice versa uh my view it demands a
swift and deliberate response by federal
agencies
one aspect of improving cyber security
of the federal government
is i.t modernization uh my mgt
act which was passed in 2017
and funded allows departments and
agencies to upgrade their i.t
infrastructure how should the department
of commerce strengthen its cyber
defenses
what role does it modernization play in
this effort
senator uh protecting our networks is
vital
to our economic and national security i
think
i.t modernization is an important
component
in trying to address this incredibly
difficult complex and important issue
and if confirmed i will make it a
priority
to work with you and other members of
the committee
on this issue uh i thank you for that
let me ask you one more
question mr chairman um the privacy
shield
the ability to transfer data across
international borders is crucial to a
broad
range of companies in kansas all sizes
all industries
and to consumers who rely on global
services to help them
work learn and connect with others from
home
until last year the eu privacy shield
served as a privacy
protective way for companies to transfer
data from the eu to the u.s
that framework was invalidated in july
can you commit to supporting efforts to
ensure that companies can continue to
transfer data across international
borders
and supporting efforts by the us
government to reach a new agreement
facilitating
data transfer eu to us
yes senator cross-border data transfers
is essential for american businesses
and uh if confirmed it will be a
priority
for me to work with the department and
other government officials
to reach a solution that supports
american businesses and national
security
i thank all three of our nominees and i
say hello to senator hutchinson as well
uh best regards to uk and thank you
madam chairperson for
the opportunity to ask my questions
thank you senator moran we're going to
go to senator hickenlooper
and then following him will be senator
blackburn
yeah am i off you yes um
first uh madam chair i want to thank you
for putting together uh or
coordinating and uh moderating this uh
good form very useful uh and your quote
at the very beginning of john perry
barlow
um uh he was an acquaintance of mine and
that's notion that you're not paying for
something you're
you're the product uh is appropriate i
think in so many
ways here uh anyway i want to ask a
question for senator
uh nelson uh and
specifically president biden's skinny
budget request for nasa
asked for a robust a robust 2.3 billion
dollars
in funding for earth science programs i
uh maybe unfortunately have a masters in
earth and environmental science
and i recognize that the climate crisis
is real uh and i think that the nasa
researchers have capabilities and
they could be a important partner in
this fight i think their research into
alternative fields
uh all certain fuels solar power battery
storage
could all be important to our efforts to
address climate change on earth
so senator i want to ask what additional
capabilities would president biden's
proposed budget
increase for nasa's earth science
programs what would that increase
provide it's a very
important increase you can't
mitigate climate change unless
you can measure it and that's
nasa's expertise
understanding our planet gives us
the means to better protect it
and um i know this
is something that you feel very strongly
about
senator uh especially in the way that
you conducted yourself
as governor uh trying to protect your
resources there
in your state so
this is uh where the administration has
provided for a robust increase on
earth science and i think it reflects
exactly what we're talking about
yeah well i think it's very exciting
kind of along that line
expanding it into the the overall
aerospace
uh industry as you know colorado's
one of the nation's aerospace leaders uh
with many engineers manufacturers and
suppliers calling our state home
i know that the commercial space
industry has committed
has contributed to many of nasa's most
critical programs
how would nasa under your leadership
continue to work collaboratively
with the commercial space sector
well it's not only
critical it's essential and in fact
that is what is happening and kudos to
your state
that produces a number of those
commercial companies
so uh as we have described from the
outset
the law that we are operating under has
nasa going down a dual track
it's been operative for 11 years and
for the foreseeable future it's the same
and it hits directly at the question
that you ask on the one hand
commercial companies are allowing nasa
to get out of low
earth orbit save for nasa's
participation
in the international space station and
go
explore the heavens
and the commercial companies as
evidenced
for example by the success of the
delivery of cargo
as well as crew to the international
space station
something that nasa had done exclusively
before
but as those systems were developed with
heavy nasa participation
because of the safety factor when you
put humans on board
and therefore that
is being done as we speak as we look to
the future further out in space
back to the moon and on to mars
we're going to see commercial
participation and we're seeing that
as we speak in what was announced last
week
and the down select in a competition
for the first
human landing on the moon
but there's a lot of commercial activity
that
is going to then be followed on
competition senator sir let me cut you
up just because i want real quickly
i'm out of time this always happens uh
and though i want to also just quickly
very very quickly
ask you about national space council on
their ability to
play a role as a interagency
coordination
uh on space policy issues that in many
cases transcend
federal agencies and just about out of
time i'm so i am out of time so it's
very concise uh as a matter of fact i
support the national space council and
was delighted to see that uh apparently
the president has decided that he wants
to continue that
uh right whatever it is you need a forum
like that because space is not uniquely
to
nasa it's not uniquely to
the department of defense space is
involving
everybody and you need that coordination
among agencies
thank you absolutely i just wanted i
appreciate i was very excited when i saw
the white house
from that i i just want to hear those
excitement in your own words
thank you all and i yield back my time
thank you thank you
thank you senator blackburn then uh
senator markey and then senator scott
so senator blackburn uh thank you madam
chairman
and senator hutchison so good to see you
uh thank you for joining us today and
uh senator nelson i so enjoyed my
conversation
with you and discussing a little bit
about
a mutual friend that we have
and also discussing your enthusiasm for
nasa but i think more importantly
your understanding of the processes
and the goals for nasa so
uh briefly and for the record what i
would
like for you to do is talk for just a
little bit
about china about china's push
into space exploration how they utilize
that civil military fusion
in order to try to beat us at the space
race
and it beat us as we look at
our military because china is out for
global dominance so
if you'll just touch on that yes ma'am
well we have known and is articulated
presently by the president
uh there is a threat
china poses in uh
basically getting a lot of our secrets
and getting a lot of
technology and invading a lot of our
privacy
now when you take that uh
global concern that we have and you
bring it to the
space program then
you have to be concerned about the same
thing
china has said that
they want to have a landing of humans
on the moon more recently
china has said that they're going to
link up with russia
to put humans on the moon
i think uh there's a lot uh
more that has to be done by saying it
and actually doing it
because space is hard uh but
i think we need to be concerned about
that
and well i agree with you on that
and i tell you i think we're going to
hold you to your commitment
of uh back to the moon by 2024
and to mars by 2030 and uh
i also for the record want to state how
much i appreciate
your um focus on the public-private
partnerships
and making certain that we are cost
competitive
as nasa moves forward with
different ventures so say thank you for
that
um miss khan for
just one question for you if you had
been
at the ftc during the obama years
what would you have done differently in
the merger
review process
senator i think over the last few years
in particular there's been
a lot of evidence that's come to light
that suggests that
in certain cases there were missed
opportunities for enforcement actions
um as i mentioned earlier i think part
of that was due to some of the
information asymmetries
part of that was also because there was
an assumption that digital markets in
particular
are fast moving and so we don't need to
be concerned about
potential concentration in these markets
because any exercise of power will get
disciplined by entry and by new
competition
now of course we know that in these
markets you actually have significant
network externalities and other
reinforcing advantages of data
in ways that make them much more sticky
um such that you know we have to be much
more vigilant
relating to these acquisitions so you
know i think in hindsight
there's a growing sense that some of
those merger reviews were a missed
opportunity
um i i i would like for you to submit
for the
in writing a more complete answer as to
what you would have done
differently we know what the problems
were
but and you know that i have concerns
about your background
and lack of experience in coming to that
position so why don't you just submit to
me
a written answer in that regard uh miss
kiernan
uh thank you so much for the time and
just
very quickly i've got 25 seconds left if
you
will talk a little bit about where your
focus will be on
spectrum policy
thank you senator i enjoyed our time to
visit
before the hearing uh as you know
the ntia has an important role in the
interagency effort
to develop a government-wide spectrum
plan and i think
that we need a government-wide spectrum
plan that will
allow us to address both the needs of
the private sector to have spectrum for
5g
as well as the government's needs
for spectrum to satisfy its needs and
its ability to perform
its responsibilities
thank you thanks madam chairman that
completes my questions
thank you senator blackburn next is
senator markey
thank you thank you madam chair um
welcome back
um uh bill your your uh
uh your leadership is uh really going to
help our country
uh in uh in an enormous way thank you
for
being willing to serve once again um
nasa
uh has more than two dozen satellites
in instruments observing key climate
indicators
nasa is the premier agency for observing
and understanding changes to
the earth could you talk a little bit
about how
you would work to ensure that nasa is
providing
uh all of the capabilities which are
necessary
to fight the climate crisis thank you
senator and i enjoyed talking with you
uh at length uh in our zoom call
as i said to uh senator hickenlooper
you can't mitigate climate change
which is happening unless you measure it
and that is uniquely nasa being able to
measure
from all the instruments that nasa
designs
builds and puts into orbit
and thus by that
understanding the earth that allows
us the opportunity to protect it
this of course is one of the major
thrusts of
president joe biden and
nasa is uniquely positioned
to try to help if i'm a
venture i'm not going to take a lot of
time but just to
give you one personal vignette
when i had the privilege of flying 35
years ago
with the naked eye from that altitude
as we orbited the earth you could see
the effects on the climate for example
what we were doing to mess it up i could
see over the amazon
i could see the color change
from that altitude of where they were
destroying the rain forest or coming
over madagascar
they had cut down all the trees you
could see the result of that because
there was no topsoil to hold the soil
when the rains came and you could see at
the mouths of the river
all of the silt that were flowing out
into the bright blue
waters of the indian ocean so
now we're so much more prepared
to measure what is happening thank you
by the way and and and that's why nasa
is going to be
so important and it's why senator
duckworth
and i have introduced the environmental
justice mapping and
data collection act so that we can
see where the harm is occurring
and then direct as president biden wants
to do
the funding towards those communities
towards those places
that have suffered the most
environmental injustice so
we just really looking forward to
partnering with you on that
and miss khan i recently sent the
federal trade commission a letter
highlighting evidence that the
edtech company prodigy education engaged
in unfair
and deceptive practices research
research shows that prodigy's online
math game
manipulates children and families into
making purchases
by constantly telling kids what items
their friends have
bought in the game and in the game
a child user who bought a premium
membership
floats on a cartoon cloud while a kid
who didn't buy a membership
walks on a dirt path
so can you please commit that
if you're confirmed you'll work to use
your full authority
under section five of the federal trade
commission act uh to ensure that we hold
companies
accountable when they attempt to
manipulate
and monetize uh the activities of
children
absolutely senator and i think some of
these dangers are heightened especially
given the ways in which the pandemic has
rendered families and children
especially
dependent on some of these technologies
so i think we need to be especially
vigilant here
thank you and and finally i authored the
child online privacy protection act back
in 1998
and again you have just bad actors which
are out there
always seeking to manipulate and
take advantage of of children will you
commit that
if you are confirmed uh that if there
are any updates to
copper that you're going to prioritize
protections for
children not loosening them uh as many
companies seek to achieve in order for
they
so that they can exploit these kids for
their own monetary benefit
senator in my view the previous rule
should be the floor not the ceiling
um not being at the commission i'm not
privy to what the current status of the
copper review is
more generally as we think ahead about
the future of kids privacy i see your
kids act as really an important
framework as we move forward
beautiful thank you thank you madam
chair thank you senator markey senator
scott
i want to thank chair cantwell um now
and thanks for nomination for being here
uh senator nelson nice to see you uh
cf3 uh nominated for nasa um
and thanks for taking the time yesterday
can you we talked just about the
importance of florida to nasa
can you talk about what you think in the
role
of nasa you can do to help continue the
growth we've seen in florida over the
last
decades
yes indeed senator and uh it's a very
robust
uh future uh as we see more and more of
this activity
now humans americans on
american rockets launching from american
soil
that is all happening specifically at
the
kennedy center and the canal space force
station
we're going to see more of the
commercial
activities we're seeing for example
blue origin that has now
contracted with the
air force and now the space force
uh and uh they're not only uh developing
a very complex
law pad but they also have a rocket
manufacturing facility
they have leased land from the kennedy
space center
and it's a big operation uh so
i think uh there's a plethora of
other companies that are gonna be uh
both preparing manufacturing preparing
and launching from that part of florida
now
why why
the middle part of central florida
on the east coast because the rotation
of the earth
gives you that little extra boost that
you don't have to spend the fuel
as you go into orbit
why south the closer you can get to the
equator
likewise you've got that earth rotation
that helps you going into earth so
i think it's going to be a very robust
future
for uh specifically florida but other
states as well yeah i think bob cabana
has done a great job
he's done a terrific job what they've
done on the privatization there is
it's remarkable what's what's happened
we talked yesterday about
communist china and you talked about the
wolf amendment uh
which restricts agencies like nasa from
partnering with china can you talk about
talk about that the importance of that
yes and we just addressed that in a
question
with senator blackburn and
thank you for pointing out uh
congressman wolf
passed an amendment that is law
and it basically says that you don't
cooperate in space unless there
is a sign off by the fbi
that this is not going to threaten
national security or the national
economy that is the law and nasa will
abide by that
and you and you you think it's important
to continue to hold china accountable
uh indeed and i expanded further in my
uh
comment with uh senator blackburn
and and that is that uh
you just better be uh concerned because
now
china is getting together with russia
and saying they're going to
go to the moon together that's a long
time until that happens we hope
nice to see your family here too by the
way so congratulations on your
nomination
thank you thank you senator sullivan
thank you madam chair and uh to our
nominees
congratulations uh senator nelson good
to see you again sir
um i wanna just ask um
about this issue i'm a big fan of nasa
and the space
agency and all that's happening and i
always ask our nominees
i remember when i asked our previous
nominee here
to me there's so much we can be doing to
inspire our youth
one of my favorite movies is the martian
hollywood doing something really great
for our country which is
a good thing inspiring young americans
there's so much going on
we had um a group of alaskan students
that had their essays
that were part of the mars
perseverance rover so these are alaskan
essays on mars right now it's pretty
cool what what can we be doing
in that uh area um you have a lot of
experience
but to me one of the most important
things we need to be doing is inspiring
our youth it's stem education it's all
the great scientists there's so much
that we can do i think we're just
scratching the surface
uh indeed senator and thank you for your
enthusiasm
with regard to spa
i'm enthusiastic there is so much
that we can do uh by
igniting the imaginations of those kids
and often you ignite that imagination
through the space program in
science technology engineering and
mathematics
and the proof's in the pudding of what
happened after
the original mercury gemini and apollo
and we saw a whole generation of
mathematicians and engineers and
technicians that came
out of that that exploded
our advance as a country
compared to others on the planet
and if you all decide to approve me
this is one of the areas that i want to
really
uh pour the juice to in nasa
as requested by the white house
the president has given a boost in his
recommended budget
to the stem area and
it's just nothing like space that can
get kids
excited good well i think you'll have a
lot of good
partners democrats and republicans who
want to help you
in that regard i think it's a huge
opportunity
i see it everywhere um so we we should
get together and work hard on that i
look forward to doing that with you um
miss kieran uh senator scott and i
later today are going to go down on the
senate floor and try and move our
legislation
that has been
really just a result of enormous
frustration that we have with cdc right
now
in cdc particularly as it relates to
cruise ships senator
nelson might care about this issue as
well has this
very myopic view on health
that it's only looking at the virus no
matter what
the health impacts are on other elements
of our economy
communities in my state
if we don't have another cruise ship
season we do it safely
we're going to put thousands if not tens
of thousands of my
alaskan my fellow mask is out of work
cdc doesn't care
i have talked to them i have worked with
them
the good news is i talked to the
secretary of commerce who seems to care
i need your commitment to confirm to
work with this committee to work with
all of us
on the proper balance between health
economic health
and dealing with this pandemic right now
the cdc
is a myopic organization that looks at
just one tiny issue
and when you have thousands of people
out of work or being put out of work
that has health impacts hugely in
communities can i get your view on that
yes senator um i think helping
the tourism industry recover
from the effects of the pandemic is a
priority of the department
and you certainly have my commitment to
work
with you and other members of the
committee and
officials within commerce to try to
identify
ways to resolve the um the issues that
you have identified
great thank you and miss khan i want to
ask you very another contact that you're
focused on that you've been focused on
um there's been some recent events that
have drawn attention to major league
baseball's unique
judicially created antitrust exemption
why does major league baseball need such
an exemption especially when we see
other sports leagues thriving
without any antitrust exemption you're
an expert
in this area you have a view on that one
yes senator my sense is that generally
congress has viewed it as appropriate to
grant exemptions when there are deep
power asymmetries in the market
um i'm not sure that the mlb would
really fall into that category so i
can't really you know
from the traditional set of criteria um
i don't think it necessarily
you know make sense but maybe there are
other justifications that
people thought were appropriate so
you're a skeptic of that judicially
created
exemption is that what you're saying to
me i think
exemptions are most appropriate again
when you have deep asymmetry such that
like one side of the market needs to
coordinate or come together
um i i don't really right off the top
see what the asymmetry is with the
mlb like where are they powerless
relative to whom
um so that's the kind of question that i
would ask to try and figure out if it's
appropriate
great thank you thank you madam chair
thank you senator lumus
thank you madam chairman i i want to
tell senator nelson how much i enjoyed
being with you it's great to see you
again and we had such a great visit
um i'm delighted that you are
the nominee for nasa's ahead
and look forward to working with you
i do have some questions for you today
do you think we need rules and policies
to ensure that large commercial
constellations
are designed and operated in a way that
ensures a very low
aggregate collision risk level over
their lifetimes
uh yes ma'am and what we are having
so much
infrastructure in space that we have a
serious problem uh about some of that
infrastructure colliding
and of course you get a collision going
at 17
hundred miles an hour uh you've got a
problem
uh the problem has been exacerbated by
the fact that
uh the chinese developing an
asat an anti-satellite weapon
years ago launched it
to destroy one of their satellites
and so doing just blew it to smithereens
with
thousands of pieces uh
littering space as space junk
and so the u.s air force tracks all of
this
and as a result
when you get thousands and thousands of
pieces
it becomes increasingly uh problematic
trying to warn for example the
international space station
that they may need to alter their orbit
in order to get out of the way of this
piece of space
junk likewise sensitive satellites both
defense as well as commercial
and civilians so given the critical
assets that nasa has
what level of risk caused by these
commercial operations would nasa
be willing to accept from these
commercial activities
well i i think you put your finger
on something that has to be done in the
future and that is
uh the development of ways that when
there
is say uh uh useless
satellite that and say it's a commercial
yours is specifically commercial but it
could be a government satellite as well
if it's if it's dead then
there ought to be a provision for
getting it down
degrading its orbit of which it then
gets into the upper
atmosphere and will burn up on re-entry
i think that's something that's
already started and it ought to be
accelerated
well thanks for those answers you know
part of nasa's success in recent years
has been the focus on the partnership
between government and the private
sector
can you talk about how you plan to
continue this partnership between nasa
and the private sector
as nasa administrator
yes ma'am uh continuing what k bailey
hutchinson and i started
11 years ago setting nasa on the dual
course of commercial operations in low
earth orbit and getting nasa out
to go explore and now part of that being
the artemis program of which
you see these commercial operators that
have been competing that
just announced uh by nasa
i'm not privy to the internals of that
but what was stated
in the newspaper is a
uh going to be a continuing
source of working together in a
cooperative way
especially when you put humans on board
because nasa's got to be involved
to make sure that it's safe
one more question what will you do to
further expand the artemis accords
and ensure that the us not only leads in
the technology
but also leads in the policy realm
well i'm going to try to continue to get
it expanded and acted by other countries
that have not become a part of the
artemis
accords and and that is
for example that the moon should be a
place
that is not militarized that uh
the moon ought to be cooperative among
nations
as more and more nations participate in
lunar activity
well thank you so much senator it's as i
said so great to see you and
i think it's delightful that former nasa
administrator jim bridenstine is so
enthusiastically
supporting uh your nomination i look
forward to working with you and i want
to thank you
for your willingness to take on this
assignment
uh madam chairman i yield back thank you
thank you senator lemus um
i'm going to ask senator peters to take
over um
i think senator lee is next and then be
followed by senator peters but he'll be
chairing the committee while i run over
to vote so thank you
thank you madam chair uh thanks to all
of you for being here today miss conor
i'd like to start with you if that's
okay
uh the sixth circuit is previously ruled
that um
uh former ftc commissioner paul rand
dixon
had to recuse himself from a hearing
based
on the conduct in which he had been
involved
where he had conducted an investigation
as a member of the staff
on the senate anti-trust subcommittee
prior to becoming a commissioner
um in in light of the the fact that
you had worked on the house counterpart
to that committee the house antitrust
subcommittee
and its report on digital markets
wouldn't you be bound to follow that
precedent by recusing yourself from any
investigation into facebook amazon
apple or google thanks for the question
senator
um let me say up front i have none of
the financial conflicts or personal ties
that are the basis for recusal under
federal ethics laws
um and i would be approaching these
issues with an eye to the underlying
facts and the empirics and really be
following the evidence
would this create any of the appearance
uh appearance of impartiality issues
given your work
for the subcommittee senator you know
insofar as there are instances where
defendants before the commission
petitioned to have particular
commissioners recused
those cases are resolved on a
case-by-case basis there's no
categorical decision about that
if it were to arise i would seek the
guidance of the relevant ethics
officials at the agency and proceed
accordingly you don't see the six
circuit cases applicable
to your instance i'd want to be more
familiar with all of the relevant facts
but
i think that case involved not any
personal financial connections he had
but rather his work
on the senate antitrust sub subcommittee
right there there are a set of recusals
required
in a federal ethics laws where you are
making categorical determinations before
taking
office um with regards to pre-judgment
as i mentioned those are really recus
those are really resolved on a
case-by-case basis okay
i i've appreciated our previous
conversations i wanted to follow up with
you on a couple of things
including your philosophy on the ftc's
uh any
any rule making power that you believe
the ftc may
wield so i've just got a quick series of
yes or no questions
should agencies exercise rule-making
powers
only those rule-making powers that have
been expressly granted by congress
insofar as the ftc has expressed
authority under 6g of the ftc
act i think that would be appropriate um
but
it shouldn't exercise rule-making power
in the absence of
rule-making power having been granted i
don't have a philosophical view on that
i'd want to think about it i think in
the context of the ftc
i i think that question is obviated by
the fact that there is express authority
in the statute can the ftc
utilize rule-making power to get around
precedent with which it disagrees
i'm not sure i mean you know section
five has a
there's a standalone basis to section
five and there's you know
core precedent noting that the contours
of section five are not limited by the
antitrust statutes
um as we discussed yesterday you know
there are gonna be some questions of
first impression
here but generally you know they're
going to be several checks on the ftc if
it does go down this road
now you mentioned um section 6g of the
of the federal trade commission act were
there any limits
that the commission um to what rules the
commission could promulgate
under 6g um in order to define
what it means to engage in unfair or
deceptive trade practices or unfair
methods of competition
yes senator as you know you know the the
contours the precise contours
of unfair methods of competition
rulemaking has been
debated um at the commission for decades
um there are a series of cases from the
80s where the ftc adjudicated
and you know courts came up with a few
standards
relating to coercion or oppressiveness
in practice though i think adjudication
has not been very successful as a
mechanism for defining the contours and
former commissioner josh wright in
particular has also written about this
so i think there are some real
questions still remaining as we've
discussed in the past
there is uh some debate currently
underway about our antitrust laws
and about the consumer welfare standard
which we we've discussed a little in the
past
it's always important for us to evaluate
our laws and and to
ensure that our standards for assessing
whether particular behaviors
uh and mergers and acquisitions uh are
illegal or should be illegal uh
whether they're harming americans do you
think the consumer welfare
standard is lacking my in my academic
capacity i have critiqued the consumer
welfare standard i've questioned whether
it really is a good proxy for
competitiveness
especially in the context of digital
markets so
when assessing whether a merger or york
is anti-competitive do you think courts
and enforcers should take into account
take into consideration um uh
any impact that the action in question
might have on innovation
yes absolutely consumer choice also
generally speaking i mean the statute
says you know substantially less in
competition competition is not defined
in the statute so it's you know
it's up to the agencies and the courts
to really figure out what this means
price market access effects on quality
all all should be taken into account
exactly
and and all that's great to hear i i
think that's fantastic
all these things all are already in play
um and they play a significant
role in our current antitrust law um and
they're an aspect
they're all features of the consumer
welfare standard it seems to me that our
laws
um could meet the need um if if only
enforcers
brought the appropriate facts and the
approp appropriate evidence in the
appropriate cases to the table
thank you mr chairman i see my times
expired
thank you senator lee for your questions
uh and to uh to
each of you here before us
congratulations on your nomination and
thank you for your willingness to serve
uh to serve your country and our country
these are big jobs that each of you are
been nominated for and uh we look uh
forward to uh this process and i wish
you
the best should you be confirmed uh
senator nelson
uh it's a particular joy to see you uh
here today it's very fitting
to see you here at the committee hearing
just in a different
position that i'm used to uh of seeing
you over the years but
it's great to see you nominated for uh
this position
uh something that you're imminently
qualified
to do uh and your passion for space uh
is legendary
uh and uh it's wonderful to see you here
it's great to see
your wife mrs nelson wonderful to have
you here i think i saw your daughter
here as well so it's a
a family affair you know senator one
thing that
always struck me in working with you is
you talked about your experiences
in space uh uh and the fact
of the vision you had from space as you
look down on the planet
and saw this uh beautiful planet uh
based and no lines between
countries just one earth together
and then to remind it all of us that
we're one people and we're on a very
small
planet and a very large universe and
that we need to come together and try to
dispel some of the partisan divisions
that tend to dominate
far too much here in this place so i
know you bring that spirit of
bipartisanship as
should you be confirmed as a as a nasa
administrator and certainly something
that
we need throughout government my
question though to you
in statement uh is is that nasa is of
course
famously uh noted or known for the
kennedy space center in florida which
you've had the privilege of representing
as a senator
the johnson space center in texas uh
certainly it's a nationwide effort but
we have some great efforts in the state
of michigan as well that supports this
this is really a country coming together
for this uh mission it includes places
or
companies like atlas space operations up
in traverse city
to futuramic in warren working on sls
rocket and many other
uh projects and other places all across
the state it's always a danger i now
mention a couple of companies there are
a long list of those companies that are
there
not to mention the work that we have
with our universities
as well and nasa has dozens of companies
all across every single state in the
union
supplying parts to nasa's deep space
rocket
the sls orion spacecraft all of the
different projects going forward
we discussed earlier this month that you
would be willing to come to michigan
and uh i want to invite you again to
come to michigan to talk about how we
deepen that supply chain i think it's
critically important that we harness the
innovation that is exist
exist in these small companies all
across our our country
and i want to kind of hear your thoughts
how do you see deepening the supply
chain
so that small companies have a
reasonable shot
to do business with nasa and bring their
incredible innovation to the forefront
for your efforts it's essential to the
supply chain and there are preferences
for small businesses but
the the strength of this country is uh
our ability to uh
manufacture by bringing in all of these
supplies
and when you get to the complexity of a
spacecraft
uh you're having to draw from many
different places and they have to be
just exactly uh how they are designed
in order to work and
so i look forward to coming back
to michigan i've been there several
times in my former capacity
senator and look forward to visiting
with you
specifically some of your space
community
well i will look forward to that uh and
hopefully we will do that soon uh
if confirmed get you into the state so
you can see firsthand
some of the incredible work that's being
done there i currently
sit as chair of senate homeland security
and government affairs committee and
we're very active in federal procurement
and want to make sure that as the
federal taxpayer money is being spent
that it is always a priority to spend
that money
in the united states to employ domestic
workers we have without question our
ours our
skills of american workers are the best
in the world we've got the best workers
engineers
scientists here that we want to make
sure that that money is focused
into our own country so my question for
you is administrator
to to the extent that is permitted by
law
how will you work to prioritize domestic
supplies for for nasa it's a
very important part for president joe
biden
in his uh buildback better and by
american and uh we will
operate accordingly at nasa in as much
as
is possible well i appreciate that uh
thank you for your answers
and look forward to working with you if
confirmed in the years ahead
thank you thank you senator peters thank
you for holding down the fort here
and and uh for getting us through more
questions
i do think we have a few members left
who still want to
ask questions but i'm hoping in the next
15 or 20 minutes we'll be able to
wrap up the hearing unless unless we
come back with a big demand from
comments already made
so uh senator cruz if you're ready uh
senator cruz is next followed by senator
rosen
thank you madam chair welcome to each of
the nominees
senator nelson good to see you
congratulations on your nomination uh
you and i spoke
a few weeks back and uh as i told you
then as i've said publicly uh there are
not
many biden nominees about whom i am
enthusiastic
uh and your nomination is a notable
exception to that
um and and i'm enthusiastic because you
and i have worked together for a lot of
years
uh and i know that you genuinely care
about the mission of nasa that you
genuinely care about space
and exploration uh and american
leadership in space
and you and i together as chair and
ranking
on the space subcommittee have worked
for a number of years have authored
bipartisan legislation together
focused on continuing america's
leadership in space
focusing on maintaining nasa's
position as the preeminent space agency
in the world
uh and focusing on ensuring also that
there
are not dramatic discontinuations
of ongoing projects within nasa that we
have both seen
with any change of administration there
is a risk to nasa a risk that
billions of dollars and thousands of
man-hours will be thrown away
as the agency changes course
dramatically and so we've worked
together whether the transition is to a
republican administration or a
democratic administration
ensuring that there is a continuity
uh that that continues the the
tremendous leadership and progress we're
seeing in space so i'm very glad
uh to have your nomination i look
forward to our continuing to work
together in now different capacities
and senator i want to thank you for your
continued leadership
after i left the senate you senator
cantwell
senator cinema did the nasa
authorization of 2020
it not only did that continuation that
you're talking about but
also trying to extend the life of the
iss
and so thank you for that well
absolutely and that's
extending the life of the iss is
something you and i have worked together
for a long time on
um i i i know the answer to this but
i'll ask it anyway which is i
i assume you support the full
utilization of the iss
beyond 2024 at least through 2030 and as
long as
technology allows the iss to be safely
utilized
uh and we are seeing some of
the fruits of the laborers over the
years
not only of international cooperation on
the international space station
but some of the research that is
occurring and i'll just pick out one
as a result of pharmaceutical research
on the station
we now uh scientists have
developed the way to more effectively
uh insert
the drug ki truda in cancer research
uh i i think that's right and one area
that i've been very focused on that i
look forward to
continuing to work with you on is how to
incentivize more commercial development
on the iss
in space and how potentially to create a
revenue stream
uh for further exploration to come from
the conversion commercial developments
that
that the federal government has
facilitated and i think there
there are lessons in terms of how
universities have handled it
uh incentivizing innovation and
developing revenue streams from it that
i think on the space
side uh we could learn important lessons
miss khan congratulations on your
nomination as well
as you know i have deep concerns about
big tech
and and the power of big tech and i
believe
the ftc should be doing much more to
rein
in the anti-competitive abuses of big
tech
to rein in the blatant
censorship and and the hubris
demonstrated by big tech what are your
views
on the risks posed by big
tech both on a competition side and on a
consumer protection side
and in particular the risks posed by
censorship and imposition of their views
upon the free market of ideas
senator i've been quite public about my
concerns um about concentrated power in
the context of digital markets
i think on the competition side we're
continuing to see a whole range of
potential risks
one that comes up across the board is
the way in which
being able to dominate one market gives
these companies in some instances the
ability to expand into adjacent markets
and the self-reinforcing advantages of
data make it much easier to capture an
entire ecosystem
i think on the consumer protection side
there are some really interesting
questions to be asked
specific to behavioral ad based business
models
insofar as you know these business
models really incentivize
endless vacuuming up of data i worry
that in some cases
you know some of these companies may
think it's just worth the
cost of business to actually violate
privacy laws so some of those are some
of the concerns that come to mind
um and i think you know it seems like
these are growing
increasingly bipartisan concerns well i
look forward to working with you on them
and i
i will say in particular i think there's
a lot more the commission can do
in terms of promoting and ensuring
transparency from big tech which right
now is incredibly opaque
thank you thank you senator rosen
ah thank you chair cantwell uh ranking
member wicker thank you
uh to all the nominees for uh your
continued commitment to public service
and of course senator nelson i
so enjoyed the conversation that we were
able to have
uh last week and so i want to talk about
women
in space and stem senator nelson we have
the
artemis program of course and nasa is
aiming to put the first
woman on the moon so as senator
klobuchar noted earlier
incredible women at nasa have paved the
way for more women in space
but we still have a huge gap in
representation
research has shown it's critical to
offer stem
opportunities and workforce development
at an
early age especially to reach girls and
other historically underrepresented
groups
of those students who eventually work in
the aerospace and defense workforce
71 of young professionals report that
they first became
interested in those careers in grade
school
so nasa conducts stem education outreach
activities at
all levels uh k-12 internships
all of it and like senator thune i'm
particularly interested in the nasa
epscor uh the joint federal state
program designed to allow more states
like nevada to participate in space and
in aeronautics
so during our meeting last week earlier
today in the hearing i was pleased to
hear your continued support of
that program and others so senator
nelson what other investments
should congress should we be considering
for nassau to ensure that today's school
children those kids in the third grade
today that we
inspire them uh to reach for the stars
i guess if you will and we want to be
sure they're well equipped
so what do you think we can do that how
do you think we can best do that
uh indeed we can
inspire this generation of
students in ways
that otherwise they might not get
inspired
through the space program we have seen
this in the past
we saw that happen after the apollo
program
to the moon for we saw that suddenly for
an entire generation
kids were turned on to science and
technology and engineering and
mathematics
and so the president's
budget as recommended to the congress
is having a significant increase in stem
in little old nasa
and if you all give us the resources
if if i'm confirmed uh then we want to
really pour the juice to this
to get these stem grants out to your
universities
uh that's going to be uh very important
and then
of course you say uh how what are
techniques that we can use
you know we uh in nasa uh readily use
our astronauts and our retired
astronauts
as a means of delivering the message
which uh students seem to just
it fires their little imaginations
and uh we want to try to continue that
too
well i can tell you i was one of those
kids who
watched all through the 60s we were
glued to the tv for every space launch
for landing on the moon and
hey i became a woman in tech so uh maybe
it had an
impact on me there but i'd like to move
on quickly to a data security so ms
khan said i'm a former computer
programmer systems analyst i
understand firsthand the importance of
data
cyber security a pandemic that forced
all of us to transition to work from
home to telework
of course hackers took notice and
they've impacted every sector from
health care to school
to business you name it unfortunately so
last year i
introduced several bills aimed at
protecting
and strengthening their cyber security
capacity
such as improving telework cyber
security for small organizations or
small businesses hit particularly hard
or school districts with ransomware
and the like and so we need to continue
to do that
and we we need to work on those
collaborative
uh efforts and guidance through support
through cisa
and the ftc so miscon how can ftc
better partner with the private entities
to build a stronger
uh defense against data breaches how
will you promote
that working relationship
senator let me say right off the front i
think you know the harms of lax
data security are immense and i think
what we've seen over the last few years
is that this is no longer just about
identity theft anymore you know there
are real national security implications
and so far as we've seen some state
sponsored hacks as well
um on with regards to um the you know
work with of the ftc with uh
private groups my understanding is that
the commission has been doing
um you know as part of its education and
outreach campaign specific work with
small businesses
i haven't had the opportunity to see any
empirical data on the efficacy of that
work but
i'd look look forward to learning more
about that
well i look forward to working with you
on that because our small businesses
really need a lot of help to do their
own cyber hygiene and continue to
maintain
upgrade and patch the commercial
software that they use it's particularly
important in this day and age and
thank you for your willingness to serve
i believe my time is
up thank you madam chair thank you
senator rosen
and i think that concludes the number of
commerce committee members who wish to
ask questions i do have
a question for the panelists that we are
making standardized in our
request to nominees and if you could
just give me
a yes or no answer if confirmed will you
pledge to work collaboratively with this
committee
provide thorough and timely responses to
our requests for information
as we put together and address important
policy issues
and as you appear before the committee
when requested
yes yes yes senator
thank you well i think this has been an
excellent hearing we've had great
participation from all of our colleagues
we've covered a lot of information
in a in a few hour period of time i
appreciate the nominees on their
questions the hearing record will remain
open though for two weeks until may 5th
2021 and senators will have the
opportunity to submit questions for the
record
we ask that the nominees return uh their
questions to the committee in a timely
fashion
so that we can move forward obviously
with the processing of your nominations
before this committee and onto the floor
with that we're adjourned
[Music]
before one small step for man and one
giant leap for mankind a team of daring
space pioneers
embarked on a pair of experimental
rocket projects
to study the earth and the heavens
with eyes on the sky and the future of
space exploration
flight controllers inside nasa's mercury
control center
watched america's space program take
flight
and so here the story of american space
exploration began
you